bonjour verra que c'est ton exactement
de cette arrestation
bonjour magali prise en flagrant délit
un consul estonien a été arrêté à saint
pétersbourg en train de recevoir des
documents classifiés d'un citoyen russe
dans son communiqué de presse le service
fédéral de sécurité a révélé que le
diplomate s'appelait marc noté ajoutant
que ces actions étaient hostiles à la
fédération de russie joue beaucoup je
l'écoutais le service fédéral de
sécurité de la fédération de russie à
saint pétersbourg a arrêté en flagrant
délit un diplomate estoniens le consul
général de la république d'estonie à
saint-pétersbourg
mark lee hâte au moment où il recevait
des documents classifiés d'un citoyen
russe
cette activité est incompatible avec le
statut d'agents diplomatiques et
revêtent manifestement un caractère
hostile envers la fédération de russie
conformément aux normes du droit
international
des mesures seront prises à l'encontre
du diplomate étranger quant à l'estonie
le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères a ri les mic a
dénoncé des accusations totalement
infondées et a qualifié l'arrestation du
diplomate de provocation écoutez c'est
un nouvel exemple du fait que la russie
n'est pas intéressé par des relations
constructives avec neuf l'estonie une
ancienne république soviétique a rejoint
l'union européenne et le bloc militaire
de l'otan en 2004 ces dernières années
les relations avec moscou sont devenus
de plus en plus tendue malgré le fait qu
une minorité importante de personnes
vivant à nice tony sont des citoyens
russes ou d'origines ethniques rust le
nombre de russophones est estimé à
environ 300 milles dans ce petit pays
qui compte 2 une population totale
d'environ 1,3 million d'habitants
merci beaucoup verra pour toutes ces
précisions elle verra goffman en direct
de moscou